Ngà Hamilvà, các bạn, về phân ngon định Grand Line, ông đi Mietri Baskot cho biết
Ngà vẫn yêu tiền dải pháp chính trị và ngại dào để chấm giữ xung độ tại uc quan ra
Nhưng các buộc kia cũng có nước phương tay đạng từ choi con đợi đả phán
Theo hăng tin tắt, về phân ngon đi Mietri Baskot, khẳng định việc tiết tục chế dưới quân sự tại uc quan ra
là gió mọi đe sất đối thoại từ phía ngà điều bị bác bò
Ông cũng nói rằng, cả uc quan ra lẫn phương tay không chấp nhật, bất kì, nổ lực ngoại dào nào, nhằm tím kiểm dạ pháp phó bình
Tên bố được đưa ra trong bố cảnh hai nước của hợp két thúc phòng đàn phản triết thử bà tại Istanbún
của những kì mà không đàn được kết quả nào đối phá ngoài có thêm thỏ thận cho đối của bình bà bình xí
Rào chăng thì vẫn tiếp diễn ở nhiều khu vực với uc thế nghiệm về phía mắt thử bà
Bố có phòng ngà ngà Hamilvà cho bây giờ, lực lượng nước này đã kiểm soát thêm 2 ngôn lạng ở miền động uc quan ra
trong đó có khu độ thi imali iqa, nằm trong tình đi đi pro patch rock, nơi mằng ngà vô tình bố không sắp nhập